roger pic et jacky car guéï ans après
avoir suivi les armées vietnamiennes
dans la guerre avec la chine sont
redescendus vers le sud
ils furent les premiers il ya quelques
jours à entrer dans ce cambodge interdit
aux occidentaux
encore une exclusivité encore un
événement en neuf ans le cambodge n'a
pas connu moins de quatre changements de
régime
trois révolutions trois guerres civiles
et une guerre étrangère du cambodgien
sont passés de sihanouk le neutralisent
talonne noël amis des américains puis à
polpot l'inventeur d'un radicalisme
sanguinaire de gauche un radicalisme
singulière de gauche sans exemple dans
l'histoire du monde et puis après ils
sont passés au régime actuel établi
après la guerre avec le vietnam mais qui
tentent de reconstruire un pays
complètement anil
mais s'il ne s'agissait que des effets
négatifs de quelques révolutions non les
images de piqué de kharg ayant vont vous
le montrer au cambodge il n'y a plus
rien les choses de la vie les plus
simples un peu d'eau ou poignées de riz
un toit quelques lieux familiers une
famille tout ça a disparu volatilisé
rien rarement à ma connaissance un pays
est autant à refaire totalement
il y a quelques jours au cambodge nous
avons vu la population en migration à
travers le pays dans tous les sens ayant
abandonné les grandes cultures
collective obligatoire du régime des
khmers rouges flanquées de misérables
ustensiles de cuisine et de quelques
poignées de riz
les cambodgiens avance irrésistiblement
sur les routes tir en traînant tout ce
qui peut rouler
les gens se cherchent veulent retrouver
leurs foyers
espérant reconstituer une femme les plus
favorisés ont récupéré des boeufs et des
chariots
ils font deux fois plus de chemin que
les autres chaque jour
mais pour aller vers 3 aucun d'eux ne
sait ce qu'il peut espérer retrouver de
ce qui fût il y a quatre ans sa maison
sa paillote dans les villes ou dans les
campagnes
aujourd'hui tout est détruit
tout est bouleversé le cambodge est un
pays à refaire de fond en comble cet
exode à l'envers c'est la fuite d'un
cauchemar
mais c'est aussi la marche vers
l'inconnu
combien sont ils personne ne plus
raisonnablement est sérieusement être en
mesure de le dire il faudra attendre
longtemps pour qu'un recensement
permettent en tenant compte de ceux qui
ont fui la guerre le régime de lon nol
et celui des khmers rouges d'évaluer
avec précision ce qui reste d'un peuple
martyrisé
[Applaudissements]
ces vagabonds à la recherche de leur
devenir ne peuvent pour le moment être
des marcheurs acharnée pour qui chaque
jour se pose avant tout le problème de
la faim beaucoup d'entre eux se dirigent
vers phnom penh la capitale qui comptait
trois millions et demi d'habitants à la
fin du régime de lons dole et que les
khmers rouges avaient fait totalement
évacuées en trois jours au lendemain de
leur prise du pouvoir retrouver la
grande ville c'est pour ces gens
l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
la sécurité de l'insertion dans une
structure sociale et urbaine mais trois
mois après la fuite des khmers rouges il
est impossible aux nouvelles autorités
de laisser le flot des réfugiés pénétrer
dans ce qui n'est aujourd'hui qu'une
ville morte sans eau sans ravitaillement
et qu'il faut réorganiser de fond en
comble avec une poignée de responsables
alors on n'entre pas la grande cité est
toujours fermé et à chaque entrée de
phnom penh les postes de garde refoulent
les réfugiés vers les camps provisoires
de la périphérie
là ils devront attendre d'être recensés
et d'être affecté au fur et à mesure des
possibilités
quelques-uns d'entre eux cependant sont
autorisés à traverser la ville pour
poursuivre leur roue de l'autre côté du
mékong et certains privilégiés sont les
premiers cadres qui vont prendre un
poste de responsabilité dans un des
services qui se met en place petit à
petit dans phnom penh afin de préparer
sa renaissance
mais comment redonner vie à ce qui n'est
aujourd'hui que le fantôme d'une cité
comme un immense décor de cinéma
les maisons de phnom penh ne sont plus
qu'une suite de façade morte de coquille
vide sans armes
après avoir forcé la population il ya
quatre ans à quitter la capitale en
quelques heures
les khmers rouges ont ensuite
systématiquement détruit tout ce qui
dans les maisons symbolisait la
civilisation décadente à l'occidentale
le boulevard monivong centre commercial
de phnom penh n'est plus qu'une sinistre
suite de magasin fermé les rideaux de
fer ne protégeant que des capharnaüm de
détritus ce derrière cette apparence de
ville endormie
tout est cassé démoli sa cage et les
appareils électroménagers les meubles
ont été défoncée à coups de hache
les conduites d'eau sont éventrés les
installations électriques démantelé
aujourd'hui pour laisser la population
réintégrer ces maisons il faut avant
toute chose reconstruire les
canalisations et la station de pompage
et d'épuration de l'eau il faut aussi
que les autorités soient en mesure
d'assurer le ravitaillement au fur et à
mesure du retour des citadins la banque
nationale symbolisait pour les khmers
rouges
la corruption du régime précédent et les
méfaits du capitalisme polpot la fit
sauter à la dynamite
peu après sa prise du pouvoir ayant
aboli la monnaie les réserves de billets
ne sont plus que papier sans valeur
le régime des khmers rouges devaient
aussi s'en prendre à tous ceux qui de
près ou de loin se rattache à la
religion la cathédrale de phnom penh a
été rasé et la pagode du pommeau au lieu
bouddhique au centre de la ville a été
saccagé ce prestigieux monument qui
donna son nom à la capitale caire a
conservé son apparence extérieure à peu
près intact mais à l'intérieur du temple
à l'exception du grand bouddha d'or ce
n'est plus qu'un bric à brac de statut
mutilés et lacéré
sur les murs de la pagode cruelle ironie
de l'histoire bouddhique
les fresques naïves transposait par
anticipation le massacre les cambodgiens
les grandes avenues sont désertes ou
encombré de débris de toutes sortes
le palais royal curieusement semble ne
pas avoir souffert et dans la grande
cité vide chaque rencontre avec la vie
semble être un mirage
la gare centrale sans trafic ni
voyageurs l'ancienne ambassade de france
transformée en garage et en campement
dortoirs des chauffeurs plus nouveau
ministère des transports l'ambassade de
chine dont le nombreux personnels
abandonna la ville avant l'entrée de
l'armée vietnamienne des canes en
chinois abandonné dans la retraite des
khmers rouges
conséquence de la guerre révolutionnaire
le grand pont sur le mékong totalement
détruit sera longtemps encore un
handicap de plus à la renaissance de la
ville
en plein centre de phnom penh l'ancien
lycée toul sleng avait été transformée
par les khmers rouges en pénitencier
pour les ennemis du régime
chaque salle de classe est compartimenté
en petites cellules dans la cour le
portique de sport devenu potence avec
des tranchées charnier à côté
méthodiquement les vêtements des
victimes étaient récupérés et l'on a
retrouvé après l'entrée des troupes
vietnamiennes
des dizaines de cadavres nu enchaîné
dans les classes cellules des salles de
torture sont encore tout maculé de sang
séché
[Applaudissements]
personne ne sait combien de malheureux
ont connu ici la souffrance des aveux
pour empêcher les infiltrations pour
contrôler la ville déserte
quelques postes de garde sont implantées
au carrefour des grands axes souvent les
soldats du fox front uni de salut
national du cambodge voisinent avec les
bo doï vietnamiens omniprésent discret
mais efficace
ce sont eux qui assument l'essentiel
parfois en longues peines nous avons
rencontré par hasard ce groupe de khmer
rouge prisonnier accompagné d'un seul
soldat armé
selon les autorités de la ville beaucoup
d'entre eux se rallierait au fuchs et il
serait déjà intégré les nouveaux
responsables cambodgiens proclame
d'ailleurs l'abolition de toute
discrimination de la population et la
création de comités populaires
d'autogestion mais il a encore
impossible de savoir quand la vie
urbaine pourra reprendre quand la ville
sera autre chose qu'un no-man's-land
quadrillée par les forces de sécurité
une poignée de cadres administratifs
s'installe cependant dans les ministères
un gouvernement cambodgien essaye de
légitimer sa réalité à sa tête monsieur
young sam rim
monsieur le président comment
pensez-vous réorganiser votre pays après
les événements tragiques que le peuple
khmer a connu consomme rien
l'aud jpy parts après l'anéantissement
de notre nation et de notre peuple par
le groupe des traîtres pulp aux tiens il
sary nous avons pris à coeur de résoudre
les problèmes posés par la vie de chacun
afin qu'elle redevienne normale estaing
l'inconscient nous voulons que notre
peuple et de quoi manger il ya de quoi
se vêtir et des médicaments pour se
soigner
nous avons établi également un programme
pour relever l'économie que la bande de
paul potts arriva détruite sous
l'instigation de pékin nous avons un
plan de reconstruction du pays en marche
vers l'établissement du socialisme et
titre à betty king notre peuple en
beaucoup de difficultés et de nombreux
obstacles causés par la bande des trade
polpot ieng sary qui ont complètement
tout détruit nous avons cependant une
ferme confiance en la conscience et
l'héroïsme que notre peuple qui a une
longue tradition de lutte et qui sait
supporter la souffrance
comment définissez vous monsieur le
président les rapports du nouveau
cambodge avec le vietnam qui me semble
qu'il brille
l'eau coupet qui est notre peuple et le
peuple du vietnam ont jadis comme
aujourd'hui des traditions communes de
lutte contre les ennemis communs qui ont
envahi notre pays
nos trois pays le cambodge le vietnam et
le lard la room se maintient nous avons
lutté côte à côte pour libérer nos trois
pays respectifs et les construire chacun
selon sa ligne rien pire récemment notre
peuple a lutté pour libérer notre pays
et renverser le régime des traîtres paul
podium ça de plus nous sommes unis avec
le vietnam pour protéger victoire contre
les impérialistes et les expansionniste
qui ont envahi nos deux pays
nous désirons enfin établir des
relations avec la thaïlande et tous les
autres pays épris de paix et de liberté
ainsi qu'avec le mouvement des
non-alignés c'est aussi à phnom penh que
nous avons rencontré ce groupe de jeunes
recrues khmer quelques dents de la
voisine leur servent de cantonnement et
l'entraînement militaire se fait dans la
rue ils sont dans l'ensemble très jeunes
de 14 à 22
les appelés du nouveau régime
équipés d'armements récupérer sur le
terrain et vêtu comme ils le peuvent
vont partir après une formation
accélérée pour renforcer les unités qui
avec les troupes vietnamiennes harcèle
des poches de résistance et khmers
rouges
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais bof
[Musique]
le gros de la population ceux qui
attendent le retour à la ville nous les
avons trouvés dans les camps de la
périphérie
ici au km 7 le long du mékong
ils sont peut-être vingt mille trente
mille impossible de le savoir avec
précision s'organisent entre eux
centraide partagent les quelques vivres
précieusement sauver ou distribués par
les nouvelles autorités
il faut aussi s'identifier
toutes les listes d'état civil ayant été
détruite par le régime des khmers rouges
dans ce camp des instituteurs se sont
fait connaître et ont déjà organisé une
petite école au milieu des paillotes et
des baraquements improvisé spontanément
quelques cambodgien parlant français
sont venus vers nous pour témoigner
raconter leurs souffrances et celles qui
étaient les habitants et comme l'un des
habitants que les amputant ainsi ce sont
les riches sur les terres sont les
fonctionnaires quand tu rigole quand il
sait que sa saison l'as enregistre un
limitait les richesses et les
fonctionnaires
voilà qui amène au phare et à la forêt
avec un bâton à la tête
norma familiale et 14 personnes et ils
essaient laisser me reste 7 seulement
envoyer les six enfants avec ma femme ma
mère l'a quitté l'école qui tue
vous avez assisté à la scène moi ça va
je n'ai pas le droit d'assister mais je
vis à la mode esmod ébloui de deux
assists et sa demande de mes photos qui
titille n'est plus famille le problème
essentiel le long du mékong
c'est toujours celui de l'eau potable
rien d'autres encore que le grand fleuve
sans doute riche de poissons mais aussi
passablement polluer est source de bien
des maladies
[Applaudissements]
et
dans ce camp quelques rares infirmiers
improvise un premier dépistage afin de
prévenir les épidémies
mais comment intervenir sans médicaments
ni équipement d'un plan de peine une
douzaine de médecins seraient en train
de préparer le premier hôpital de grande
urgence j'étais à rome sera ton père
j'étais institutrice et que s'est il
passé
et après 60 ans le 17 avril soixantaine
c'est déjà ce que tous les magistrats du
rapport
nous avons perdu 3 3 enfants et mon mari
était perdu aussi je sais pas et liteo
mon fils m'a mon fils tu le deuxième
prise là il était au lycée 18 mars à la
classe de terminale elle été injustement
combat mené par porto l'a aisément et
mas marty deux pays au seuil était morte
par maladie sans médicament ema vie
était très dur
oui oui thierry dans la forêt profonde
qu'est ce que vous faisiez la rizière
comment se passer vos journées de
travail dans les rizières matin au look
est réveillée dès trois heures du matin
pour aller travailler jusqu'à onze
années mais pour déjeuner une meilleure
et après c'était votre déjeuner avec du
sac
mais après toute ma vie après une
demi-heure en fait travailler encore
jusqu'à 10 heures ce sera déjà la nuit
et ceux qui ne pouvaient pas travailler
nous avons passé deux jours dans ce pas
désemparés et impuissant au milieu de
tant de détresse et pourtant cette
volonté de survivre de faire renaître un
pays c'est elle sans doute qui peut
encore sauver ces gens donnent une
chance à ses enfants
[Musique]